oui
bonsoir à tous les frontières sont elles
nécessaires à l'humanité question très
intéressante aujourd'hui je commençais
par deux anecdotes la première printemps
1992 des soldats français
casques bleus sont en observation sur
une frontière intérieure de l'ex
yougoslavie
ils assistent impuissants à l'exécution
de civils par des paramilitaires rien
faire s'ils font quelque chose c'est un
déclenchement d'hostilités
quelques années plus tard il ya pas si
longtemps 2013
nos soldats combattent les djihadistes
dans le nord-mali soudain
un jeune garçon bardé d'explosifs
s'avance vers nos soldats malgré le
stress malgré l'adrénaline
malgré la menace nos soldats n'ouvre pas
le feu ils discutent ils obtiennent la
reddition sans dommages du jeune garçon
ces deux exemples vous montrent la
complexité de la notion de frontière où
nous parlons beaucoup la frontière
effectivement peut gérer les relations
entre états oui les frontières peuvent
aussi gérer le fonctionnement d'une
société dans notre société nous tuons
pas les enfants et c'est aussi la
frontière morale qu'il ya au sein de
chacun d'entre nous face à une situation
complexe
la frontière est bien partout alors ça
soulève de nombreuses questions
la première que je vous ôtera est
finalement qu'est-ce que je suis bien
légitime pour vous parler de frontières
eh bien oui oui je suis tout à fait
légitime sans aucun état d'âme officier
général depuis près de 40 ans la pac est
près de 40 ans d'officier après saint
cyr
toute ma vie je me suis préparé à
défendre d'abord contre le bloc de l'est
et ensuite à franchir dans d'autres
circonstances des frontières au premier
exemple d'ailleurs été très jeune jeune
lieutenant au sud-liban casques bleus
chef de section de chars le 6 juin 1982
l'opération paix en galilée l'armée
isralienne avec plusieurs dizaines de
chars au moi de mon côté envahi le sud
liban pour marcher sur beyrouth
je reçois l'ordre de ne rien faire je
dois expliquer surtout à mes soldats
pourquoi nous ne faisons rien la mission
est de défendre de protéger cette
frontière mais nous recevons l'ordre
nous obéissons je me suis longtemps posé
la question de savoir si nous avions
résisté qui nous n'aurions pas empêché
cette invasion du sud liban en raison du
contexte international que sera est
posée quelques hommes quatre chars 40
hommes facettes dizaines de chars nous
aurions peut-être pu faire quelque chose
c'était une frontière était franchie
pour beaucoup et deux que nous n'avons
pas franchi
alors cette frontière ne conduisent
naturellement aussi à d'autres questions
qu'est ce qu'elle est qu'est ce qu'elle
n'est pas posons-nous vais aussi la
question de savoir dans le monde dans
lequel nous vivons
qu'est ce qui prime l'émotion prime
puisque la raison et encore ce monde
incarne interconnectés que voyons nous
entendons nous tous les jours nous
n'avons plus besoin de frontières et que
finalement un monde sans frontières
c'est l'avenir de l'humanité
pourtant vous ici ou ici présents vous
avez bien une famille que vous protégez
vous avez bien une maison vous protégez
vous avez bien un jardin avec un enclos
une barrière vous avez mis des règles
pour protéger votre famille la frontière
est partout même chez vous pour qu'elle
existe et vous ne pourrez pas l'effacer
bon qu'est ce qu'il nous reste à dire
aussi maintenant qu'est-ce qu'une
frontière
comment peut-on la définir dans un
premier temps joe réfute la frontière
symbole du repli sur soi deuxième temps
je réfute aussi l'absence de frontières
comme avenir d'humanité alors qu'est ce
que la frontière à la frontière pour moi
c'est très simple c'est un sas un filtre
qui permet de prendre le temps de la
réflexion et en fonction de ce temps de
réflexion
cela va nous contraint à engager le
débat sur l'existence d'une frontière
pourquoi est elle la première question
ou peut-être pourquoi n'y en a pas et
puis la question suivante ça va être
dois-je la défendre à tout prix dois-je
à laisser franchir à tout prix où
dois-je la rente poreuse en fonction de
critères de conditions que j'aurais
déterminée et je vais aborder cette
notion de frontière à tafer trois
domaines le premier domaine très simple
que tout ne connais bien c'est celui des
relations interarabes étatiques les
relations entre hectares
à partir de trois symboles le premier
symbole est sans aucun doute celui de la
division
oui une frontière ça c'est par ces
divise pourtant 1989 nous en avons parlé
tout à l'heure
1989 le mur de berlin lors de berlin
séparé le même peuple
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale et
finalement le peuple a décidé de
détruire le mur physiquement
courageusement j'y étais quelques jours
après puisque j'étais chargé de
communication envoyé de paris auprès du
gouverneur français gouverneur militaire
français de berlin et nous sommes posé
des questions sur les suites à donner
qu'est ce qui allait se passer après je
vous rappelle qu'à l'époque de sites en
pleine guerre froide que les chars
soviétiques existait et qu'après tout le
mur détruit voulait peut-être dire une
nouvelle guerre mondiale donc le mur
interpellait c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire
finalement il s'est rien passé et nous
avons aujourd'hui une allemagne
réunifiée mais il ya d'autres murs vous
avez ces murs effectivement qui
s'érigent à l'est de l'europe pour
d'autres raisons
cette fois ci c'est pour protéger ou
interdire des migrations
vous avez aussi le moyen-orient on peut
réfléchir profondément sur le mur entre
israël et l'autorité palestinienne dans
d'autres raisons et puis bien sûr
naturellement vous avez ces murs naturel
physique que montagne comme une mer
méditerranée entre l'afrique et l'europe
mais finalement tous ces murs ce sont
des défis pour l'être humain
vous savez comme moi que l'être humain
de toute façon aime les défis et des
leurres car une frontière un mur à
franchir il essaiera de franchir
c'est peut-être de dangers de la notion
de frontière un deuxième symbole de
cette frontière est sans aucun doute
celui de l'autorité
quand on met une frontière quelque part
c'est qu'on ne veut pas qu'elle soit
franchie sans votre accord
3 ira pas besoin de frontières
une barrière et je vous invite à
réfléchir
en cette année de commémoration de la
première guerre mondiale à nos poilus
dans leurs tranchées tranché nouvelles
frontières physiques sur le territoire
français bien loin des frontières
retirer de droit essai français
dans les tranchées disaient ils ne
passeront pas en parlant des allemands
sachant qu'une autre frontière était
derrière cette frontière entre la vie et
la mort la mort au combat pour tenir cet
engagement
et beaucoup ont donné leur vie pour que
les autres ne passe pas troisième
exemple troisième symbol le symbole
vivre ensemble paradoxalement une
frontière sert à déterminer un espace
géographique et humain qui va apporter
sécurité bien être à une population
donnée
c'est aussi l'acceptation de normes ce
soient des normes administratives
politiques mais aussi une histoire
partagée une langue une culture la
frontière c'est aussi à cela c'est quand
même important
donc voilà trois symboles importants
concernant les relations internationales
le deuxième domaine que je vais aborder
avec vous et celui de du contrat social
au sein d'une société tout temps dans
toutes nos sociétés nous avons un
contrat social qui met ensemble de
règles de loi de règlement de loups de
coutume aussi qu'ils vont nous permettre
de mieux vivre ensemble
encore faut t qu'elle soit acceptée lors
d'aucun ou d'aucune diront oui ces
règles servir du passé
ces conservateurs c'est obsolète
pourtant
ne sont elles pas la transmission de ce
qui a été fait par ceux qui nous ont
précédés vous permettre de vivre
aujourd'hui et éventuellement des faits
révolue pour demain se lever quand une
personne âgée ou une femme enceinte
entre dans un transport en commun est si
obsolète que cela pourtant tous les
jours nous voyons bien ça ne se fait pas
dire bonjour dans un magasin c'est
pareil ça fait partie de ce contrat
social là par le jeu de l'éducation et
des coutumes mais cette transmission
suscite aussi une manière indirecte la
notion de transgression toute société
démocratique permet la transgression des
règles
une manière du lourd trop qu'on puisse
en dire si une forme de liberté
transgression pour différentes raisons
manque d'éducation refus du système
rebellion pourquoi pas
parlez pas de la crise d'adolescence
après tout quand vous assister dans un
transport en commun toujours un exemple
à des personnes qui mettent leurs pieds
sur un siège
c'est bien refus de respecter les codes
en vigueur dans la société
c'est une manière de s'affirmer vous
allez me dire mais est ce que ce n'est
pas un rejet du contrat social qui nous
unit plus grave la liberté manifester
inhérentes à un fonctionnement
démocratique d'une société parce qu'on
exprime ses idées
comment accepter aujourd'hui que toutes
les manifestations que nous voyons ou
pour la plupart sont des manifestations
qui se finissent par de la violence non
pas pour défendre ses idées vous pour
essayer d'attaquer physiquement ce qui
représente notre société qui représente
peut-être la république et ses valeurs
comme les forces de l'ordre il ya un
dévoiement justement de ce contrat
social
alors pourquoi parler de cela et parce
que simplement tout contrat social
signifie quoi
la libre acceptation de règles de normes
ou ça nos sociétés afin de mieux vivre
ensemble en vue quand même de développer
ce sentiment de respect mutuel ce
respect mutuel qui est le ciment d'une
société troisième domaine la frontière
morale
je sais que mon moral fait toujours peur
mais ça fait rien frontières morales la
frontière morale que chacun d'entre nous
doit d'avoir parfois à faire face dans
le cas de situation difficile
je prendrai bien entendu un exemple
militaire il ya des zones très précis
l'obéissance et la désobéissance obéir
aux ordres reçus en fonction des
missions qu'on a aussi reçu et savoir si
à un moment donné on va pas désobéir
simplement parce que l'obéissance n'est
pas une fin en soi
l'obéissance est un instrument en vue de
l'objectif qu'on veut atteindre
il faut faire preuve d'intelligence de
situation est donc cet exemple de no
border désobéissance et bien d'une
frontière qu'il faut savoir franchement
pas franchir à l'été 1992
je sors du celsa dans la foulée comme on
dit chez nous je suis projeté en ex
yougoslavie au sein d'un régiment
français dans une province
sécessionniste
la situation est tendue nous avons perdu
deux officiers sur une mine le
cessez-le-feu est fragile
notre colonel est sur le terrain il
rencontré belligérants pour éviter que
ça dégénère
soudain il fait nuit vers 23 heures
nous sommes deux au pc au quartier
général donc en charge du régiment nos
postes d'observation nous signale de
blindés d'un belligérants qui a franchi
la ligne de cessez le feu sans
autorisation
c'est une violation à la fois physique
de la frontière qui était établie et
c'est aussi la violation du droit qui
avait été mis en place et peut être
aussi un test de notre volonté d'agir
nous rendant compte je connais elle nous
dit vous détruisez les chars s'il reste
dans votre zone bien
mon camara et moi nous concertons sauf
deux officiers supérieurs
il est 23 heures on est un peu seul donc
on échange
premier point nous n'avons pas le mandat
des nations unies pour utiliser la force
sauf en cas d'échec team défense
deuxième point nos soldats sont en
pleine relève relais voulant dire qu'au
bout de six mois sur le terrain nos
soldats seront passés par des soldats de
france ils sont en cours d'acheminement
ça veut dire que les soldats que nous
avons utilisée sur le terrain ne
connaissent pas le terrain et de nuit
nous savons que pour des tirs des chars
nous aurons des pertes
nous décidons tous les deux de ne pas
exécuter l'ordre si nous devons
l'exécuter et nous attendons une heure
deux heures
à un moment donné à nos postes nous
signale que les blindés ont franchi la
ligne dans l'autre sens l'incident est
clos
la mission continue mais nous ne
parlerons plus jamais de ce qui s'était
passé
encore moins notre colonel jusqu'à ce
soir ans pour conclure la frontière est
nécessaire pour l'humanité allez
nécessaire parce qu'elle lui permet de
progresser car lui permet de poser des
questions et si elle pose des questions
de réfléchir avant d'agir et avant de
faire un choix ne va peser toutes les
conséquences c'est aussi à amman une
manière de réguler les mauvais instincts
qui nous caractérisent souvent par quoi
qu'on puisse en dire
nous avons beaucoup de mauvais instincts
on le voit tous les jours une frontière
sert aussi à réguler les mauvais
instincts alain point positif cette
frontière néanmoins avec une source de
défis l'individu aime le défi et
l'individu aime franchir les frontières
il faut en tenir compte mais franchir
une frontière
c'est aussi montrer qu'on a du caractère
mais aussi ne pas franchir une frontière
c'est peut-être aussi faire preuve de
courage
on n'est pas obligé de dire qu'on ait
fait parce qu'on n'a pas franchi une
frontière
peut-être que de ne pas franchir une
frontière c'est qu'on a été courageux je
livrais un adage pour conclure
définitivement que j'ai un peu modifiée
que vous devez connaître et qui me
semble bien résumer cette notion de
frontière ma liberté s'arrête là où
commence celle des autres mais toujours
amènes
la liberté des autres s'arrête où
commence la mienne et puis il faut
toujours se rappeler que quand on a
franchi une frontière et qu'on s'est
peut-être trompé il sera toujours il est
souvent très difficile de revenir en
arrière je crois qu'il ne faut jamais
l'oublier
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les